in the book in defense of looting they
basically said that
or i saw it could be wrong so fact check
me said that uh jewish people and asians
represent the face of capital
and then a bunch of people are like that
sounds an awful lot like what you know
nazis were saying
but it's it's it's they're they believe
a lot of the exact same things so
they want the plane of godwin's law what
they wanted to do was get rid of
oppression or or
diminish oppression the feminists and
then they conflated patriarchy with
oppression and that's where that skewed
that's like where hitler conflated
the jews with the banking power
structure that he wanted to overcome or
whatever the power structure he
he thought that just because a lot of
jewish people were in those positions
that it was the jewish i don't even know
i think the dude was just
like he went after jewish people for
sure but as it accidentally
be as the feminists went after men
accidentally because they were just
trying to undo the oppression system
so the fake oppression system yeah and
the zoo
critical race is they're trying to undo
the white people but what they really
want is to undo the oppression well this
this is the joke if whichever group you
want to be a part of
you got to figure out who your target is
if you want to be an occupier the one
percent
the one percent is responsible for the
war they're the one who controls the
bank and the money
if you want to be you know a conspiracy
theorist the illuminati
illuminati you know they're making all
the wars and basically you can take any
one of these groups
any group anti-racist fascist whatever
and you can ascribe
all of the same problems oppression and
conflict and strife and suffering
you want to be a communist well the
capitalists are causing the war because
the war machine the capitalists are the
ones
who are oppressing you you just pick
whichever would be change the noun
and all of a sudden congratulations to
whichever group you want to be it's a
failed tactic
that's a i mean it's a tactic that leads
to what we're seeing right now i mean is
it a failed tactic i mean they're
getting
they're they're like chipping away at
the patriarchy they're chipping away at
this sense of oppression well i guess
the argument would be that it will
destroy us in the long run well that's
what we've been trying to say and that's
why we're trying to fight back i've
been tweeting and writing about this for
years it is woke
versus men or woke versus masculine
energy
and we need to have a revival of
masculine
energy you know you know what's really
interesting to me i grew up watching
shows comic book shows you know like
superhero stuff
and they always have the men and women
on equal footing you know
i never really thought about it so when
i was when i was little watching say
anime or superhero stuff you see wonder
woman
she's you know depending on the on which
what you're watching she's like
top tier superhero as strong as the man
or stronger actually
there are a bunch of there's tons of
anime where there's strong female
characters with like
top tier abilities and they're like main
characters and so in fiction
the ideas created among particularly
among you know young people who watch
this stuff that men and women are
equally powerful and then something
interesting happened when
when when i was skateboarding and i
turned 16
and then all of a sudden it was like wow
there's a real power disparity between
men and women and skateboarding
then i turned 18 and i went to the x
games and i was with my friend
and i got to meet a bunch of the top
female skaters and i mean with no
disrespect at all but they just don't
compare to the men
and then all of a sudden i heard from
the mouth of one of the top female pros
you will never be as good as a man
and that she was telling the to the
other women i thought it was interesting
to grow up seeing all this fictional
content where men and women are equals
on in every way
fighting each other or sometimes women
are stronger captain marvel for instance
but then you go out in the real world
and you watch sports or work and it's
like
men and women are clearly different i
really i really i have a lot of strong
feelings about this i've been containing
myself
i really hate this idea that men and
women need to be on an equal plane well
not that they need to be on a
playing field but they need to be the
same because i'm seeing a lot of the
idea that they have to be the same like
women can be stronger than men like
captain marvel really did not make me
happy i was like why should a woman need
to be as strong as a man
why don't you find something interesting
that a woman really is good at in real
life
and you empower normal women to do
normal woman things to do them really
well
and to like assign some kind of value to
that because that would be interesting
but what would be different but
i think about uh like sparta right i
think it's the spartans
the only i i don't know if this is true
but i read that the only way a spartan
would get a gravestone
is if they died in war in battle right
and the only way a woman would get a
gravestone
gravestone is if she died in childbirth
i don't know if that's true but i was
like i was watching 300 so i started
like reading about sparta and stuff like
that i like your but oh
well i was going to say like if if
jumping into a burning building
you know and pulling out the the puppies
and the children and saving them
is a masculine thing being the hero
being the strong adventurer the warrior
what would a feminine you know
movie be what would the heroic female be
doing
raising alexander the great yep training
impressive
training you know look there's a phrase
there's a saying the hand that rocks the
cradle rules the world
interesting right so khan's mom it's the
moms that put ideas into the kids heads
and it it's
it's the it's the women that the men
desire
that spur men into conquest into
creation and to building things
and to protecting and preserving things
so like that game of thrones
where you have the the women who are you
know high-ranking positions
who are royalty or whatever and the men
are all fighting the war and stuff yeah
i don't who dramatically got this idea
that it's like
it's better to go to war and get chopped
up in a meat grinder than to stay at
home
and to take care of the farm and the
kids but not but but that's but but
that's even
still uh we're talking about the the the
peasant class or the working class
yeah you like in looking at game of
thrones you had tons of female
characters who were in positions of
great power
who were directing the men to go into
the meat grinder and go to war for them
and so there was a lot of drama and a
lot of power behind what they did
you look at those characters like cersei
lannister was extremely powerful
now mind you i mean the show kind of
trailed off and nobody cares anymore but
i'm using as an example that
you've got uh a lot of shows where you
can see female power and how they wield
it and how it's represented
and it's dramatic and it's it's
fantastic well i mean look there's
in and we're talking about spanish latin
culture and spanish language
it's el sol right masculine and la luna
yep
right right okay and then and then it's
it's also
mother earth right so we we have in
us in our history and our archetypes and
our dna and our evolution this idea
that there are polarities yeah jordan
peterson and you need them both
and that like the great caretaker
that guards us all and provides this
warm safe wet environment for us to live
in
you know it's female energy as well you
know it's really crazy
what's the stereotype of when uh when a
soldier is is
dying what does he yeah he screams out
for his mother yes he does
he doesn't yell dad nope he yells mom
mother you lived inside her for nine
months that's crazy yeah man
that's that's that that that to me is
one of the greatest like uh disrespects
of of that of modern feminism
that there is kind of it feels
and i'm not saying this of all women i'm
not saying of all feminists but there is
a general like
ignoring of the power of motherhood and
femininity
kind of gets me diminished like they're
like i i
one of my one of my friends just
ignoring they are tearing it
down well so one of one of my friends
posted on facebook how
she got uh i don't the right word is for
it but she can't have kids anymore
by choice she went to a doctor oh
location i i
i guess it's like two times but more
than that like
irreversible hysterectomy no no no not a
hysterectomy but where they use like
high heat to cirrhosis yeah or something
yeah so it was a tube tube's tied
followed by cauterization and they were
celebrating that they'll never be a
mother
and i was like why do you feel that way
you know like why would you go through
that
i mean it's your life you can do what
you want i'm not telling you you can't
do it i'm just curious like why would i
be interested
and i wonder if it's a product of
society telling young women not to be
this way
and then you think about like uh who's
that woman
abigail schreier i think yeah so uh joe
rogan had
this uh this woman on who is talking
about like rapid onset gender dysphoria
and stuff and how it's typically young
women being told
they're trans because they like doing
certain masculine things
and so it feels like there's there's two
fronts here
that are targeting young women and
taking away their agency one telling
them that they shouldn't be they
shouldn't like what they like
there was a reddit post that went pretty
viral i think
you might know what i'm talking about
you gotta oh you gotta look on your face
like you knew this one no no it was it
was a couple saying we're raising our
daughter to be genderless but she keeps
demanding pink dresses yes
our three-year-old yeah you know
whatever and i was like
that's fine maybe that's what she wants
like why would you deny that if your kid
has made a choice you know what i mean
like that's
so then they're telling their kid not to
want these things and then when their
kid says okay they go aha now you should
go to the doctor and get you know
hormone therapy
or something right so one of the main
concepts
of critical race theory is queering
right so queer
is not a noun anymore it's a verb and it
means to break down
barriers it means to change categories
right like to queer something means to
take it from what it is and transform it
into something else usually like it's
opposite
i never heard this yeah yeah james
lindsay writes about it all the time and
yeah so
it's you're queering a thing right
that's why you can have
you know straight otherwise says
whatever
girls calling themselves queer yeah is
because in their mindset they're like
trying to help
you know shred the boundaries and now
this is a theme that we see
everywhere right now which is the
elimination of boundaries
right you can see it from globalism you
can see it in social media you can see
it
with the pandemic you can see it with
gender we are the
the last 23 years have been about trying
to obliterate boundaries
so that there's no way to actually
identify
who you are one of the ways that you
identify who you are is by identifying
what you're not right right and you can
take note over here and over there and
over there
and then you get a sense of self and
that sense of self leads to
individualism and individual
accountability and it leads to
capitalism ultimately
so so what they're trying to do is
basically we'll all be wearing gray
jumpsuits with shaved heads
and uh well uh it's it's what uh what
what's that what's
in bergeron yes harrison bergeron you're
familiar oh my god yes i mean
just here talking to you guys i have my
iq limiter on
okay just so just so i can fit in
i'm highly offended the thing in your
ear we actually have a program running
to make sure jack doesn't run circles
around us
in fact all of the guests on this show
everyone except for me
are we related constant screech that's
your sequel
you said something very interesting
lydia about um
men and women being on an equal playing
field and that metaphor made me think of
a football field and you would never put
a man and a woman on a football field
together because the man would dominate
the woman yep that's 99.9
that's exactly what i was thinking of
when i said that i was like if you put
them both on a football field they're
not gonna be anywhere near the same but
if you want someone to give your kids
the right ideas
you're not going to ask dad to do all of
it you're going to need a mom
so well more importantly i think mother
and father
can provide different perspectives for
the kids
but if your kid needs nourishment you're
not going to be like cycle the teeth of
papa
you're going to be like the dad can't do
that so maybe men and women should be on
equal playing field metaphorically
sometimes but sometimes not that should
be
they should be treated equally under the
law right right and
have agency i got in trouble a long time
ago for writing a satirical piece
that was trying to just help women
understand that they need to
have agency feminine feminism is about
taking away
women's agency and that's why you see
people criticizing
the supreme court nominee right right
because she had kids and babies so she's
a terrible person she made this choice
or when women are like i just want to
stay home with the kids
you know what i love about amy coney
barrett they're like she's literally in
a cult where she thinks she's
subservient to her husband she's a
handmaiden and going to be not
and nominated the highest court in the
in the country and yeah probably one of
the most powerful people on the planet
so none of it makes none of it makes any
sense
and the way that we know for sure that
none of it makes any sense
is in the scandinavian countries where
they're the most liberal
and they give people the most freedom
and they can and they can
choose whatever jobs they want and yet
more women choose jobs that involve
people and
care and men involve jobs or take jobs
that involve
things and thinking it happened
naturally and they're mad about it
but apparently it's it's worse it's way
wider
yeah so apparently in the scandinavian
countries the more equality they offered
up at opportunity
the more the gender divide expanded i
forgot about that it makes me laugh
whereas
when you didn't so i i guess the way i
see it is necessity comes first
if you're if you're in a country and a
woman has to work she will work if a man
has to work he will work if a man has to
stand to watch his kids he will stay on
and watch his kids
rick moranis famously right famous actor
in the 80s
and his i believe his story was that his
wife i could be wrong about this but i
believe his wife died
and so he bowed out of hollywood because
he needed to be there for his kids
so the necessity drives first give
someone a socialized state
like a social program i'm not saying
socialism i'm saying social programs
where their kids can have daycare and
it's covered don't worry about it
then what happens if you've taken away
the risk the choice comes into play and
the men choose the jobs and the things
and then choose the family and they're
raising the kids
that's what we see in scandinavia in
this house i don't want to clean the
basement at all
but i'll carry boxes in all day man
absolutely
don't you make me use a bird natural
like deep desire i've just got this like
i don't want to clean yeah
i'm not going to add it i'm not i'm not
attentive to the detail of the grime
but i'll lift the boxes yeah yeah i
carry all the stuff i can happily
because i'm building muscle it's kind of
it's going to work out yeah yeah it's
almost
as if we are who we are in part
or if not 100 due to the hormones in our
biology and the way we're built
we're all here to perform a role right
and it's very clear what my role is my
role is to protect and provide
and it's very clear what a soft feminine
woman's role is to provide you know
happen in our relationship
and neither one of them is like better
than the other they're both
important and necessary to make a whole
so
feminism or being feminine is very
different
is something very different from
feminism yes yeah the collective
difference based around feminine energy
yeah what about men being feminine and
women being masculine i think it's all
it's all spectrum right it's like these
are group averages so you're
definitely going to have men with a
little bit more of a feminine energy and
women with a little bit more of a
masculine energy
it's not clearly just going to be one or
zero but they do gather around the means
outside of you know in their sort of
bimodal distribution i think
have you heard of the term the kenzie
scale yeah that's like a sexuality scale
a one through seven and that people i
don't know most people are either three
or
four yeah i'm not super familiar with
that but the thing that
the thing that bothers me the most about
feminism is that it comes in with the
name kind of like antifa
it's in interjecting the idea of a
strong feminine
and i'm like when you look at it all
you're getting is watered down versions
of males
and that is so demeaning to women it
boils my blood i was like where is this
what's special about that you're just a
second-rate man
i have time for that sorry well and
that's what's playing out on the
national scale whether we all
all of us know it or not this is a need
for more masculine energy
and leadership and also a
re-establishment of categories
and boundaries which is why we see
people wanting to pull back from
globalism
that's why we see people thinking social
media is not healthy for them all the
time
that's why we think that's why we see
social distancing
is a good thing in terms of in times of
a pandemic and that's why we need to
have clearly defined gender identities
and gender roles because
boundaries matter and boundaries that
you let things in when you want let
things out when you want
no boundaries means there's no people no
thing
there's nothing if if everything is
everything then
nothing is anything that's why i say
it's a chaotic and destructive force
yeah you got that that's why it's a
chaotic destructive force yeah
it's just you know at one point it was
it was anti-globalist now it's
pro-globalist
and now it's just moving around randomly
burning down buildings and destroying
things with no real
purpose or plan well let's let's talk
about that
to what extent are these people just
spontaneously deciding to go do this or
that or burn this or attack the federal
courthouse or whatever or to what extent
are they being guided and led to a great
extent
but it's it's it's opportunistic in the
sense that there are people in politics
who
want to channel that rage towards
something they can win with and i think
the democrats tried using that
i think that they saw the the anger uh
so this is this is why
it is what it is well right this is this
is why
uh we had all this crazy rioting and
anti-war stuff during
during bush and then as soon as obama
won they were gone
because it was it was being manipulated
and weaponized but the
but but now the internet is guiding it
now now there's people online saying go
do this and they just do
so now it's just randomly popping up and
it's out of control it's like it's like
a flame that can't be put out
do your thing twitter yeah it's it's
there's one of the things i explained to
my friend that you know she asked me how
do we stop all the crazy cancel culture
stuff and i said
like the simple answer really is donald
trump and the republicans for one reason
social media companies and media have no
problem banning conservatives who get
out of line
but they're allowing the left get a line
we need to set the boundaries for the
left because these companies won't do it
so if we allow them if we tell antifa
you burning down these buildings and
killing people worked for you
it'll get worse if we collectively
reject all of that and say no
and they realize their temper tantrum
doesn't work we have to be the one
saying the boundary
because the companies the big tech firms
aren't going to do it they're going to
allow them to organize and
invite incite violence also i would
think along the lines of people thinking
emotionally and not logically rather
than looking at it like
stopping cancel culture because you're
just saying stop cancel culture and
you're putting it out there
say what you want it to be oh yeah allow
people to speak freely
yeah freedom of speech what i've been
telling people is
look for love find love look for hate
find hate
it's your choice and i'm in the look for
love camp and that's the message i keep
trying to spread
look for love because if you look at
almost every situation you can
find that and it's when you're
constantly focused on finding the hate
when you're constantly focused on trying
to find
one little word that donald trump did or
didn't say in his debate you're going to
find it
these people on the left there right now
their whole radar system
it's like gotta find hate gotta find
depression gotta find negativity and
what does that do to you on the inside
it rots you it rots you yeah and maybe
it comes from the inside and you're
rotten already i don't know but it's
it's
a cycle this is why i was saying like uh
last week jokingly
that you know in 30 years you could make
a funny little like uh
short film where someone finds the old
ruins of the new york times building
and it's like decrepit looking and like
windows are busted out and they go
inside their flashlight and they're all
scared and then they see a journalist
and they're they're wearing a suit it's
all ripped up and tattered and their
hair is like half fallen out and they've
got like missing teeth like
donald trump and they like like zombies
and like they latch on
and they're like say something offensive
and then you do start writing about it
frantically like desperate to just
find that rage and complain about
something
and that's that's the future i envision
for these people well unless they
collapse and it's
how are we going to eradicate that that
[ __ ] that's going to happen
it's going to keep going the like
zombified
journalists looking for you know just to
write about when you're describing this
scene in my mind i'm seeing the
animation from early scooby-doo cartoons
you know what i mean like that zombie
guy in a suit with this tattered suit
and the glasses
yeah yeah donald trump is bad
it's kind of like how would you
eradicate a barren field you would you
would plant trees or
replace it with something else i don't
know that antifa this is necessarily a
barren field it could be a raging fire
that you have to put out before you
plant the trees but
well you're gonna have to oh this is an
excellent point this is excellent point
it's
time to build we need builders
this ties in with masculine energy we
need to build
things build good things build an arc
bring on the flight babysitter maybe i
mean you guys are definitely
you guys are definitely building an arc
here i saw it with the green beans and
the apple cider vinegar
the beans that last for 30 years yeah
but but
i'm not the only one talking about that
that's ian by the way i didn't buy
though
there's like 94 cases of green beans
that's not that
at least but though there's people in
the tech world and there's people in
other industries that are identifying
clearly that this
is the time to build and it's these
people that are the ones who are focused
on hate all the time
they never build anything right they
don't build they tear down and if you
are a builder you don't have time for
hate
because you're too busy building your
thing correct so we need
builders and who what kind of energy
builds things
i don't know well feminine thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you